did you apply to go to harvard or no no
i never applied to go to harvard uh i
actually i applied to go to princeton
and then i think i applied to go to
upenn wharton i think those are the two
ivy leagues that i applied to but wasn't
interested in going to harvard what you
were not interested in harvard i wasn't
interested in harvard no why not
well i knew that they won i knew that
they were discriminating against asians
so that there was kind of a moral
principled thing there but then i think
there was also kind of
uh
i i didn't like i didn't like the
culture when i toured there and
everything like that i never wanted to
apply to all seven ivy league colleges
that was never my intention got it so
you didn't like the culture but you did
go and take a look at the campus to see
if you were going to like it or not and
then you applied to princeton now
would you say princeton runs a similar
kind of a philosophy as harvard to make
sure they please
every ethnicity as they're accepting
students or princeton goes on a
different philosophy no it's the same
philosophy the ivy leagues have the same
philosophy there's there's this graph in
my book an inconvenient minority it has
it has asian american percentage as a
percentage of student body for all seven
ivy leagues and what happens is there's
like an initial spike in the 80s and
then by the 90s it goes down
and in every single ivy league school
asians are between like 15 and 18 of the
student body every single one
and then you see caltech which doesn't
practice discrimination against asian
americans and their asian population
goes from like 10 to like 40 percent you
got to be kidding me no i'm not kidding
you this is this graph is in the book
so every ivy league has the same ratio
of 15 to 18. caltech's got 40 percent
yeah
how much criticism does caltech get
uh
for not practicing discrimination
against asian americans yeah how much
credit like how who is is anybody
targeting
caltech's approach and calling them you
know many different words that nowadays
are used to
you know defame the character of that
university no one's uh really targeting
caltech right now because their
reputation is so excellent you know
their their their their school is like a
sixth the size of mit
but they they're number five in the
world in terms of research papers
produced in the sciences and mit is like
number two believable yeah is iit number
one who's who's number one is number one
okay so mit is number two caltech as you
said celtic is one-sixth the size of mit
yet they're sixth in research papers
fifth
fifth and they've gone up they've gone
up from 10th
in the past 10 years so if you like this
sort of short club from an interview i
did click over here to watch the entire
interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]